a cdc advisory committee meets this
morning to decide
if it's safe to resume the use of the
johnson and johnson one dose
covet vaccine it was paused as you
recall last week to investigate a
potential link
to a rare but serious type of blood clot
cbs news medical contributor dr david
agus joins us david good morning what
should we expect
from this meeting do you think good
morning anthony 10 days ago
they stopped and they looked around the
country and made sure there weren't more
than these six cases a couple more
showed up but it's a very small number
my gut
my opinion is today they will release
the j j vaccine for the country
there will be a warning on it so doctors
and patients are aware of what to look
for so they can treat this
abnormal blood clot early and we're
going to be back safely administering
this vaccine hopefully by the end of the
weekend or monday
you think they'll do this david despite
the fact that there is one more woman
who apparently died from the vaccine
yeah i mean what we've done is we we've
seen across the
the world now these kinds of low
platelet counts and blood clots
in several people with all of the
vaccines so this happens the spike
protein from the vaccine affects the
blood vessel and causes a response so
there's a blood clot there
it is remarkably rare so when you start
to look at this
it is much much much safer to get the
vaccine
than not and i think now that we're
aware of it we're going to be able to
treat this early without serious
ramifications
for the patient we didn't see this
though these severe cases of blood clots
in the j
g j j vaccine trials david why why not
do you think
well i mean this is i think and a
testament to how rare it is the trial
was tens of thousands of people 40 000
people
and we're seeing this at a rate of about
one in a million
so once we start to get in the millions
and tens of millions rare side effects
happen
now that there's a warning and we can
identify it early
again hopefully there won't be serious
problems from the vaccine but the
vaccine
are saving millions of lives david the
cdc says it's uh considering revisiting
guidance
on masks particular particularly for
people who've been
fully vaccinated what do you think we
should expect there
well the data are showing that this
virus is transmitted almost exclusively
indoors over 90 percent of the cases
indoors when you wear a mask
you can block that spread indoors but
outdoors especially in the vaccinated it
probably isn't going to be necessary
so my gut is that over the next few
weeks we'll see that starting to fall
down and that we're going to be
able to go outside without mass it's
still going to happen indoors
israel this weekend or last weekend stop
the mess
in outdoors but not indoors how how long
before you think we're free from masks
entirely
uh my gut is you know toward the end of
the summer is we're going to get toward
her immunity our country our company
country is going to step up and everyone
will be vaccinated who can be vaccinated
and we're going to be coming out of the
scourge unfortunately the variants are
still worrisome but i think the current
vaccines attack their variants at the
present time all right dr david agus
thanks so much